herzlich konsolen folge ich fahre leute
heute mit malerischem hintergrund ein
schloss und dahinten seht ihr auch schon
was besonderes das ist 190 sl aber leute
darum geht dass sich heute geht es um
einen wagen der über eine million euro
heutzutage kostet und eine absolute
legende ich gebe den keller unter euch
ein stichwort w 198 2 herr mister
bescheid was es ist leute 300 fr
[Musik]
und daneben steht der besitzer das ist
der ralf reller grüß ich was vielen
vielen vielen dank an reifen seine firma
automobile die uns diesen wagen heute
zur verfügung gestellt haben wir sind in
paderborn leute und wirklich ich
unterschreibe nicht wenn ich euch sage
das hier ist einfach eine unfassbare
legende dieses auto aber vor wir jetzt
hier weiter ins detail gehen leute hat
der sebastian aus dem schnitt aus köln
eine kleine info vorteil ist dass hinaus
dem schnitt aus köln und ich habe eine
chance für unseren heutigen partner für
dieses video denn unser partner wird das
video heute ist linke ist weil man
bnk s&t ich bin selbst durch diese
kampagne auf blick ist gestoßen aber ich
finde die idee richtig geil war ich
persönlich bin jemand der eigentlich
viel lesen möchte der gerne mal
klugscheißer der gerne immer über sachen
bescheid weil aber um ein großes problem
ist dass ich mich einfach partout nicht
zum lesen durchringen kann aber da kommt
links ins spiel denn genau da hilft link
ist denn die fassen bücher in 15 minuten
zusammen und den ganzen inhalt der
ganzen bücher in 15 minuten runter
gebracht das heißt wenn die raucher
konzentrations gestürzt wie ich dann ist
diese app genau das richtige für euch
ich zeige dass man eben hier auf meinem
handy so sieht der startbildschirm aus
und jetzt suchen wir mal eine sache und
zwar ein buch was ich sehr sehr lange
schon rum liegen habe aber was ich nicht
fertig zu lesen ist das kapital im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert richtig
geiles buchbar haben wir hier hier
blinkt ist ein so genannten blinkt er
stellt eben 18 minuten lang der in 18
minuten das ganze buch zusammenfasst es
könnte dann lesen oder euch sogar
anhören und ich finde die idee einfach
richtig richtig fesch man kann richtig
viel zeit sparen ganz wichtig jetzt für
euch dort es gibt exklusiv für euch ein
siebentägiges probeabo mit dann 25
prozent auf des jahres aber wenn ihr auf
den ersten link in der beschreibung
klickt linke.de scaling einfach drauf
gehen und wenn es euch nicht gefällt
könnt ihr binnen sieben tagen komplett
kostenlos kündigen leute aber dafür hab
ich bin wirklich sehr frische jetzt
weiter mit dem video es ist wirklich
unfassbar das kostet nicht ohne grund
das zu schätzen reif
roundabout heute
ist indiana wehrt aber ab eine million
aufwärts auf eine million aufwärts leute
es ist unfassbar wir machen jetzt mal
eine kleine geschichte schon zusammen
mit dem rad weil das auto ist wirklich
legendär das hat einen zeitpunkt nicht
nur in der automobilgeschichte
deutschen geschichte markiert ab dem
alles anders war ja so der geht zurück
auf den 194 richtig das war ein
rennwagen damals von mercedes entwickelt
weil mercedes im rennsport wieder durch
mitspielen wollte und dieser rennwagen
hat dann richtig richtig abgerissen
übrigens heute ich bin ein bild einen
davon gibt es eine carrera panamericana
edition von 494 paar von euch kennen
vielleicht den panamerika panamericana
grill der heutzutage auch in vielen amg
s eingebaut wird ja damals als dieser
rennwagen 300 sl entwickelt wurde gab es
aber ein problem man hat die teile
genommen vom typ 300 das war der b186
war aber alles turbo schweren der wäre
das war so ein klotz riesig groß
schwerer motor schweres getriebe wir
brauchen aber ein rennwagen dann gab es
so eine möglichkeit rahmen und
karosserie und dann kam ein genie leute
merkt euch diesen namen rudolf uhlenhaut
und der hatte die geniale idee mit dem
gitterrohrrahmen und aus dieser rennen
version 3 sl ist dann der straßenwagen
300 sl geworden leute geben ein kleines
stückchen rum also das coupé was wir
vielleicht auch kennt mit den
ursprünglichen flügeltüren übrigens fun
fact die flügeltüren hat das warum weil
er den gitterrohrrahmen und einen sehr
hohen einstieg dadurch hatte damit
konnte man keine normalen klappt eben
machen man muss eine flügeltür man sieht
das auch beim 300 sl roadster den hohen
einstieg in den breiten einstieg weil
sich hier unter der gitterrohrrahmen
befindet wahnsinn beim flügeltürer waren
nur etwas höher und deswegen musste man
eine flügeltür einbauen das ist übrigens
auch der grund warum der sls flügeltürer
hat ne nicht wegen jux und dollerei
sondern wegen dem sl 3 300 sl damals und
der hatte die flügeltüren nur als
notlösung eigentlich brasilien oder als
sehr geschickte lösung von diesem
legendären ingenieur uhlenhaut was haben
wir unter der haube leute einen
dreiliter
reihensechszylinder
vielleicht können wir direkt mal
reinschauen weil nicht nur das auto an
sich ist besonders sondern auch die
technik erster viertakt pkw mit
benzindirekteinspritzung davor gab es
nur vergaser mercedes hatte hat eine
geschichte auch mit flugzeugmotoren und
daraus auch geil wie die haube öffnet
und daraus kamen sie dann auf den
trichter lass uns noch mal eine
direkteinspritzung probieren gucke jetzt
mal hier das verrückte ist der motor
steht so der dazu hat sich gerade mal 40
grad geneigt der einzige grund warum die
haube sowfracht sein kann also die haben
eigentlich müsste der motor so sein
so stehen waren sind der kopf würde
eigentlich oben stehen man sieht ganz
klar das schwarzglänzende das ist der
kopf der geschichte ja darin liegt der
geniale idee damals war waren wahnsinn
hat auch eine trockensumpfschmierung wie
auch der sls das heißt auch eine ganz
kleine öl waren und darum mit separatem
ölbehältern spart erstmal tiefe für den
motor dadurch kann auch noch der
schwerpunkt tiefer gesetzt werden und du
hast auch bei hohen g kräfte in den
kurven immer eine optimale schmierung
richtig richtig richtig geil und mich zu
vergeben die direkteinspritzung ja zu
der zeit waren halt noch vergeblich ja
und hier ist es eine direkte mechanische
kinder einspritzung der auch geniale
idee vor allem direkt in den zylinder
rheine heute machen wir es ja wenn der
sauger einspritzung gut er entwickelt er
ist kraft ab 3.500 touren ja dann hat
auch im brachialen sound und dann auch
richtig kraft ja damals der schnellste
sportwagen seiner zeit der hat 215 ps
225 ps 25 sogar rund 250
höchstgeschwindigkeit damals schon eine
250 leute also rennwagen mit
straßenzulassung sind 250 und das vor 60
jahren der ist baujahr 61 ne frage ab
märz 61 hatten sie die scheibenbremsen
hat er die er hat keine scheidung also
ist vor mehr als 1 6 gebaut alles klar
da hat er noch die trommelbremsen drin
hat die trommelbremsen hey leute das ist
wirklich unfassbar
1805 wurden auch nur gebaut der 1400 vom
coupé man nicht 1858 vom roadster was
wir damals eigentlich war ich viel näher
als wahlhelfer in der preisklasse ja ja
das war schon die grundidee war der
flügeltürer 1954 und der 190 sl als
cabrio version und der flügeltürer als
coupé version ja und der max hofmann es
war damals der erste
exportschlager für amerika der 190 sl
wie wir da sind damit ist mercedes beruf
geworden ja und nachfrage war sehr hoch
der aber die motorisierung zu klein für
amerika und max hofmann wagte dann
mensch wir müssen die amerikaner möchten
die an schweren sechszylinder die
möchten auto mit power haben aber als
roadster ja und dann wurde 1957 der
flügeltürer eingestellt und dann kamen
der hier zu sehende rohstoffen markt
wahnsinnig komme also darüber und die
beiden autos wurden dann bis 1963
parallel weiter gebaut die kleine
motorvariante 190 sl und der 300 sl als
roadster von 57 bis 63
wahnsinn dass wir
müssen kommt man hier über leute kommt
man ja darüber was ist denn das schiff
in setting ich komme gar nicht klar
leute sorry auch wenn ich heute nicht
die richtigen worte für dieses auto
finde ich gebe mein bestes aber das ist
einfach legende da ging es los das war
deutschland das waren neun jahre nach
dem krieg als der 300 sl coupé kam und
er hat alles zerstört die rennversion
wähler 490 hat alles plattgemacht bei
allen rennen und dann kam mit 336
straßenwagen 250 damals gefahren
wahnsinn 250 heißt hat die lang
übersetzte hinterachse genau gibt es ja
noch kürzer dann rennt die nicht so
genau dort gehört ja auch für den
amerikanischen markt
wahnsinn hier ist der schriftzug
hintendrauf 300 sl wenn wir vorne rechts
meinen blick ins cockpit werfen 300 sl
steht auch noch mal hier und guckt euch
mal diese instrumente an der frist doch
einfach
wahnsinn und passenderweise weil der
reifen absoluter profi ist und alles da
hat haben wir hier auch noch ein
original prospekt vom mercedes also
wirklich reif chapeau muss ich echt
sagen und wir schauen jetzt mal rein was
gesagt eine sache müssen uns ganz
besonders anschauen und zwar wann kommt
hier kommt der legendäre
gitterrohrrahmen leute das ist ein
original prospekt von damals du hast
auch noch das original scheckheft alles
alles musste ich denken kann ist ja das
einzige was fehlt ist das den rudolf
uhlenhaut noch zum leben wieder von der
liste für dann ist die geschichte
komplett und jetzt würde ich sagen
beginn die augenweide rein und fahren
eine runde hätte die jetzt gedacht leute
denn wenn ich eine ganz wichtige sache
vergessen hätte nämlich den soundcheck
dann gab's ärger aber nicht vergessen
und deswegen würde ich sagen reifen nur
einmal rum gehst einmal startest ich
verstecke mich hier hinten
sehr
geil geil geil geil geil geil geil so
jetzt auch per 1 und da sondern heute
300 sl wir bewegen uns raus aus dem
schlossgarten habt ja losgehen gesehen
der 190er ist er gerade im hinter uns
der fed jetzt eskorte
da ist da er sagt
das ist unser kamerawagen heute ich
freue mich gerade ihm schon anschneiden
dieser ist mit einer anschaulichen also
nicht warten die leute aber ich sage
immer sicherer als elektrofahrrad
unfassbar leute oder es gibt einfach da
gab es keine anschnallgurte und deswegen
habe es gab damals so genannte becken
holte die sind aber gefährlicher als
allesamt noch immer klappt sowieso ein
klappmesser
vorderhand nicht ganz schnell
beckenbruch und
anstalt wird ohne kopfschutz ist sie so
gefährlich
das gehört im winter ist wobei die ganze
gaststätte
wahnsinn hat beim fest geschenke
vorgesehen leute hier andere zeiten
andere sitten hier war noch der
aschenbecher ich es nicht richtig
traurig doch gar nicht einmal aufmacht
deuten wir müssen ja noch mal auf den
chef draufhalten reif wirklich noch mal
vielen dank greift auf jeden fall rella
automobile ab im internet und auf
install ganz ganz großer aktionär heute
greift die erste frage ist immer was
bedeuten autos für dich ich glaube dass
er einiges zu erzählen
autos sind mein großes hobby
als kind habe ich immer schon mit 190 sl
trauner derselbe wago autos gespielt ja
das war für mich immer schon das größte
nach meinem studium meine leidenschaft
zum beruf
eigentlich wollte ich mein steuerberater
werden der plan vor 26 jahren sich
selbstständig gemacht mit einem auto aus
erst mit modernen autos die wir heute
auch noch verkaufen und dann meine
leidenschaft
190 sl
erworben und auch selber restauriert
heute restaurieren wir professionell und
sind auch deutschlandweit europaweit
bekannt die restauration 190 sl und
suchen auch alle großen messen und das
ist für mich ist es das größte auto
eine auto ikone das beste auto was
jemals gebaut worden ist
damals ein handwagen mit
straßenzulassung ja
mein auto war in der zeit die autos 50
gesagt die stundenkilometer fuhren und
dieses auto schon mit mega 250 kilometer
angegeben wurde das ist echt wahnsinn
leute ich dass ich noch nicht gemacht
aber ich bleibe mache ich einfach
nochmal werden euch mal ein bild vom b
186 1 das war der teilespender für
dieses auto und der sieht aus wie
die aus den 30ern das ist irgendwie so
ganz also absurd und dann kommt sowas
heraus
irgendwann in den 186 war schon der mega
motor drin oder heimlich schwert war an
sich ein sehr schweres auto und dann
hatte der urlaub die idee daraus einen
rennwagen zu bauen da brauchte man halt
gewichtseinsparung ja es war möglich
durch den zusammengeschweißten
gitterrohrrahmen ja der hat fast gar
nichts mit 40 kilo arena waren also
uhlenhaut ist wirklich ein name den er
hat hatte ich schändlicher weise lange
nicht im kopf aber der typ ist echte
legende beginnen der film erzähle ist
für für die automobil kunstvollen der
190 sl und zum schlepptau ist der kleine
bruder vom 300 ist er habe damals halb
so viel gekostet aber auch ein mega out
und auch vor 60 jahren also das ist
schon wahnsinn dass wir heute nach 60
jahren noch aufs auto brennen das ist
schon immer hat er noch einen
sechszylinder kleingärten 40 nach dazu
105 ps aber damals auch schon mit 170
stundenkilometern gegeben für damalige
zeiten aber schon ein mega mega haut
aber damals auch schon so viele große
desaster ein einfamilienhaus und rudert
er selber damals schon eine riesenvilla
was macht den 300 sl für dich aus kann
es noch mal kurz zusammenfassen warum
genau dieses auto fahren vielleicht
genau durch das so ich kann ja verstehen
aber die zuschauer vielleicht noch nicht
erstens die form in die mega also
angefangen vom flügeltürer mit den
flügeltüren wie beim sls wurde
wurden sie dann doch mal
improvisiert das wird auch der letzte
schlugen türer seinem mercedes gebaut
hat ja wie die karosserieform auto zum
verlieben habe ich damals als kind schon
vor geträumt und der motor beim 300 sl 1
3 liter motor mit 225 ps in einen mega
sound vielleicht können wir aus testen
wenn so ab 3.500 touren entfall der eine
mega kraft und einen wahnsinns
chh
der sound erst einmal her kraft der wird
ja unfassbar fertig
propaganda kampagne
dahinter was alles für einen scheiß
vorgang auf gerade richtig war
doha
und
wahnsinn
was denn erlebnis anstalten nicht da hab
ich habe mich schon wieder hat schon
jetzt das ist normale h schaltung jakub
losgetreten
was das eigentlich ein silberner pin
daneben fertigt schalter fertig auch im
fuß mit fuß
ok jetzt habe ich auch ein bisschen so
wo es in der schweiz pro jetzt hier
ach du scheiße wo ist der weit hinten
ach du scheiße
das ist kriminell
ach du scheiße leute ist der schrei von
weit hinten
orientieren sich gerade keinen schalter
verfahren höher
ja ja ja ja und keineswegs
ideal ist so schon mal so wenig abstand
noch man muss die autos erst
kennenlernen das ist schon was ist muss
auch so einfach wie modernes augen ganz
fahren
gewisse zeit bis man das auto kennt das
man so wirklich fahren kann krass weil
die bremse kommt so spät dass tricky
leute man hat halt echt früher schon
widerstand dem bremspedal aber die
bremswirkung kommt jetzt mit verspielt
hey leute macht euch keinen bild nicht
mehr ist das ungewohnt
wahnsinn
[Musik]
aber
ich sag mal so die autos ein denkt sich
so ja alles klar wir können direkt
loslegen und erzählen was
sie sagen ja das ist wirklich sind gar
kein tor
naja nicht
ganz unfassbar leute ich muss aber
wissen was erzählen also gigantisches
lenkrad aber ihr habt auch so ein
widerstanden natürlich dass keine sehr
wohl hier ist das ist unglaublich
geil ja
da ist der streitpunkt
[Musik]
was ist mir das nicht vorstellen kann du
bist ja ein autoexperte und
leidenschaftlicher sl fahrer aber so
viel es gibt auch so viele die einfach
nur viel kohle haben man sich 1 311
holen könnt ihr noch gar nicht einmal
die fahne haben
ich habe mich schon vor 20 jahren
eine ausstellung steht und dann gar
nicht gefahren
aber auch ein auto muss gefahren werden
ja weil die meisten jana
das ist aber auch eine schande
heute
schleifung ganz genau wissen
drei heim
möglich also ich merke wenn ich ganz
ganz außen auf dem gaspedal in meinen
schuhen durch ihre ich immer noch die
bremse also nicht ganz rechts bin das
heißt
fast allein schöpfer des kroaten ist zum
schnellfahren also zogen wir überall so
respekt das auto sportlich zu bewegen
das wirklich eine kunst
respekt
also ich muss wirklich sagen
hier fahren mit dem wagen fahre ich noch
vorsichtig das ist echter ich habe du
hast das auch nicht einfach rechts ich
komme teilweise auch beim kuppeln an die
fed nicht stellung
ich habe einfach zu große schuhe für das
ich habe auch so erfasst leute kennt und
wie viel
das geile ist die leute sehen dass immer
in den kommentaren bei blamabler hat er
bis heute
seit mitte märz mit dem reifen ich habe
meine schwierigkeiten habe mich zu
bewegen und b wir fahren hier auch
einfach wirklich unfassbar viel geld ich
die gegend also pardon wenn ich jetzt
den wagen nicht komplett über graue
haare mehr bekommen ja ich habe es
gemerkt habe ich
jetzt noch mal langsam nun hat jetzt
autobahn
kann man einmal
abgeschlossen
mein mann ist
wahnsinn
wahnsinn nicht fürs jetzt bisschen
ruhiger und -roller wieder andere
blutdruck ist wieder aufgebaut aber
viel vielen dank faust drauf
alle automobile auf jeden fall anschauen
einfach einfach in ihrem anderen und
sein ganzes team offen
hoffen euch warten jetzt fällt auch die
bewertung aller muss sich einfach sagen
leute dass das das geht nicht man kann
es eben nicht da kann man davor keine
zeiger zu machen das ist wie in der
kirche reingehen und dann die
inneneinrichtung bewerben ist das macht
man nicht deswegen hier einfach keine
bewertung heute einfach nur in der
legenden kategorie und da gibt es elf
von zehn hammer mäßiges auto legende
mehr sage ich nicht bis nächsten sonntag